let's start tonight with a brief hannity
history lesson in the so-called
norms and constitutional duties
surrounding supreme court appointments
the media mob will not tell you this top
democrats want you to believe
it would be improper for president trump
to nominate anyone
to replace justice ginsburg during a
presidential election year
that is a complete total lie in
fabrication
here are the facts we'll lay it out just
straight up
news you could use that the media mob
won't want you to see
article two section two of our
constitution is clear that the president
shall appoint ambassadors other public
ministers and judges
of the supreme court and all other
officers
of the united states the u.s senate's
role is to advise and consent in other
words
their constitutional role senators vote
whether to confirm the president's
nominee there is no exception
whatsoever in the constitution for
election years
and since our country's founding here
are the facts
there have been 29 vacancies at the u.s
supreme court during a presidential
election year
29 and 29 times before
a sitting u.s president has nominated a
replacement
in an election year well 19 of those
times when this party the same party as
the
white house controlled the house and
senate on the case of the
president and the senate aligning 17
out of those 19 judges were confirmed
in an election year when the presidency
and the senate
are controlled by opposing parties
there's been ten examples of that
well only one out of ten got confirmed
before the election two were confirmed
after the election when the president's
party won the election
so simple facts duly elected
conservatives they prefer to
appoint what we call originalists or
constitutionalists
and liberal democratic presidents they
like to appoint
judicial activists things they'll never
get done at the ballot box or
legislatively in fact the last time a
supreme court nominee was approved by an
opposing party during an election year
before the election was in 19
i'm sorry 1888 and that's when then
president grover cleveland a democrat
got two nominees approved by a
republican senate in other words 132
years ago
that didn't stop democrats in 2016 from
demanding
that the republican-controlled senate
again the other party
vote to confirm judge merrick garland
obama's pick to replace the late justice
scalia watch this
the american people deserve a fully
staffed supreme court of nine
the president nominates and then the
senate advises
and consents or not but they go forward
with the process the american people
expect jojo garland the president's
nominee
to be given a fair hearing and a timely
vote in the senate
the senate should do their job every day
that goes by without a ninth justice is
another day the americans people's
business
is not getting done when the
constitution is
100 percent clear the president of the
united states has the right
to nominate someone to be a justice of
the supreme court
senate's function is to hold hearings
and to vote
republicans control the senate merrick
garland was never confirmed as
president obama once famously stated
actually many times said
elections have consequences that
includes a republican senate majority
they can come but they're in the back
and in 2016 the american people put
donald trump in the white house in 2018
the gop increased its majority in the
u.s senate duly elected republican
senators let us be clear
as the constitution prescribes the
president will nominate
the senate will advise and consent the
current hysteria surrounding
precedent is laughable democrats they
don't give a rip about precedent
in years past democrats could have
easily filibustered
well a judicial appointment in fact
under george w
bush well guess what democratic senators
they broke
centuries of precedent they're the ones
that began filibustering judicial
nominees with regularity
the democrats did that 2003 an attorney
you might remember his name miguel
estrada became the first ever court of
appeals nominee
to be successfully filibustered he
wasn't the last
harry reid and company while numerous
judges were blocked by the democrats
using the filibuster which had not been
used prior to that
and guess what in 2013 obama's president
his fellow democrat then senate majority
leader harry reid
he broke precedent once again not the
republicans the democrats
he triggered the so-called nuclear
option which eliminated filibusters
for judicial nominees in other words
they would need cloture they would need
just a simple majority
the democrats did this now they did it
in part so harry reid could load
the all-important d.c circuit court of
appeals with liberal nominees
they have stacked the court in the past
so now as they
are threatening to do so with the united
states supreme court
which just 43 days before the election
believe they will do
it with the supreme court they mean what
they say and tonight if democrats are
upset they have nobody but themselves to
blame
and make no mistake they're very upset
as we speak they're throwing
a collective major political temper
tantrum as are their friends all over
the mob
in the media like this former fake news
cnn host having vowed to
burn the country to the ground jeffrey
toobin
so-called legal expert probably one of
the dumbest lawyers in the country
calling for unrest in the streets others
like
obama wingman eric holder when they go
low we kick him
and democratic senator ed markey they're
calling for the democrats
to pack and stack the supreme court add
as many liberal justices
as they can more democrats are
threatening to end the filibuster
altogether meaning
now on legislation which has never been
done before that's never happened
and some are vowing revenge by adding
washington d.c
puerto rico as new states why because
they figured that will be four more
democratic senators
to guarantee them a democratic senate in
perpetuity
and as chuckie schumer is now
threatening and pelosi threatening
nothing they're saying is off the table
they're threatening the entire country
to upend every precedent we've ever had
they're the only ones that have done it
in the past they opened the door
this is what they're threatening now
take a look we must
also commit to using every procedural
tool
available to us to ensure that we
buy ourselves the time necessary
but once we win the majority god willing
everything is on the table if in fact um
they are successful in placing
a justice on the court i think that what
democrats have to do
assuming that biden is president and
there is a a senate majority in for the
democrats
we need to think about court reform and
at a minimum
as part of that reform package i think
additional justices need to be placed on
the
on the supreme court now you got to
remember too not one democrat ever
spoke out about hillary's oh deleted
subpoenaed emails
and and bleach bit and hammers uh they
never once complained about her dirty
even the new york times finally called
it russian disinformation dossier that
became the foundation
of illegal warrants premeditated fraud
on a fisa court to spy on a presidential
candidate
his transition team deep into the
presidency of donald trump they ignored
all of that
and keep in mind court packing is an
unethical process that would increase
the number of justices oh let's bring
her from 9 to 13.
thereby giving a sitting president an
opportunity to control the court
it's a practice that is so controversial
so corrupt
they say they're honoring justice
ginsburg she was against it take a look
nine seems to be a good number and it's
been that way for
for a long time i have heard that
there are some people on the democratic
side
who would like to increase the number of
judges
i think that was a bad idea when
president franklin delano roosevelt
tried to pack the court but today the
extreme far-left socialist radical
democratic party
clearly doesn't agree in fact you heard
the well real speaker of the house
congresswoman ocasio-cortez saying that
ginsburg's death should quote radicalize
all democrats right on cue their speaker
in name only nancy pelosi
seemingly threatening to impeach the
president impeach the attorney general
as a tactic to stall the supreme court
nomination take a look
you in this the house could move to
impeach president
president trump or attorney general barr
as a way of stalling and preventing the
senate from acting
on this nomination well we have our
options we have arrows
in our quiver that i'm not about to
discuss right now
to be clear you're not taking any arrows
out of your quiver you're not ruling
anything out
good morning sunday morning
the we have a responsibility
we take an oath to protect and defend
the constitution
of the united states arrows in the
quiver wow
okay here we go anyway nancy pelosi
kind of malfunctions live on camera the
democratic strategy
is clear it is predictable and it is
dangerous democrats the media mob
their state-run tv across the country
their allies all over
they want to upend our entire system of
precedent the entire thing
they're throwing a massive temper
tantrum they're smearing president trump
they will absolutely vilify any nominee
this is now a common practice for
democrats it's actually
a term we call it borking after what
senate democrats did to judge robert
bork
similar disgusting baseless smear
campaigns were conducted against justice
clarence thomas
we watched the repulsive statements and
actions more recently with justice
cavanaugh
no matter who the president nominates no
matter who's qualified
or how qualified or how reputable he or
she apparently or she
will be democrats will wage a smear
slander besmirchmen campaign the likes
of which this country has never seen
what do they care they've only dragged
the country through the mug for four
years
they'll claim abortion will be illegal
they'll play on racial issues mark my
words